[Musique]
alors vous êtes Nagui après Laurent
Delahousse et Harry Roselmack le
troisième animateur préféré des Français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que les Français ont choisi
François Hollande comme président
alors vous êtes 365 jours par an sur
l'antenne de France 2 et 2 fois par jour
avec tout le monde veut prendre sa place
du lundi jusqu'au dimanche à 12h et
n'oubliez pas les paroles du lundi au
vendredi à 19h15 finalement vous gagnez
bien votre vie le grand vainqueur des
jeux que vous animez c'est vous non
il est gagnant de jeu gagne plus quand
même ah quand même mais moi c'est
régulier
c'est le drame
[Musique]
France 2 a arrêté Taratata l'émotion
était considérable surtout évidemment
chez les artistes il est resté plus que
Natasha St-Pier
Cali a failli sortir en guise de soutien
heureusement vous l'avez arrêté à temps
mais qu'est-ce que tu as contre lui
Polnareff Polnareff a envoyé un message
Johnny beaucoup d'artistes il a dit que
j'étais son enfant en Polnareff en même
temps lui son enfant est pas à lui donc
[Applaudissements]
France 2 vous a donné des compensations
donc des prime time
un jeu d'été qui s'appelait le cube et
là il y a une pétition mais pour que le
jeu revienne pas alors
vous avez obtenu une émission de cuisine
en préaccess aussi il y a eu aucune
compensation tout ça était avant alors
ceci étant vous vivez bien regardez
cette photo là on voit quand même que
cet été vous n'étiez pas
particulièrement triste vous avez passé
un très bel été ma femme je l'aime je
t'aime mon amour c'est vrai que votre
maison à Saint-Tropez s'appelle la
redevance
tu me l'as fait il y a au moins 12 ans
alors vous avez décidé de relancer
Taratata sur internet comment ça va se
passer concrètement à partir du 18
octobre n'importe quel vendredi vous
tapez my taratata.com et vous avez une
émission qui pendant une semaine est
affiché en Premium et toutes les autres
archiver mais celle qui arrivera d'abord
sera l'émission de l'actu du moment de
l'artiste principal c'est gratuit tout
simplement gratuit il y a un concert
aussi de 10 octobre au Zénith et 20 ans
de Taratata ça c'est gratuit aussi non
ça c'est ça c'est payant 45 euros et
tout et c'est déjà complet et tous les
bénéfices sont renversés à la Fondation
pour la Recherche Médicale contre ah
c'est cool vous auriez pu le reverser à
France 2 aussi
[Musique]
attention
tu connais rien tu connais rien en
musique
bientôt bravo
René la taupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est belle attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très dur c'est culte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas sûr de devoir tout trouver
parce que là ça craint un peu ridicule
c'est un animateur de télé qu'on voit
plus
et c'est pas de la rue
[Musique]
il y a des connaisseurs dans le public
Philippe et jolie bravo vous sortez
monsieur attention
[Musique]
et le dernier
au nord c'était les corons
[Musique]
la croix de bois les Russes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu